خوفي وتكر سحي خايف يجي ياخذ الولد مني
يكشف عليه يلاقيه ولد يذبح الولد قدام
طلعنا السبعه ايام هينا
قديش السبعه ايام
قديش وماحدش معترف فينا ايش رايك في جيل
اليوم يا حجه جيل اليوم والله لا علت
[موسيقى]
علي
اسمي هندومه هندومه وشاح وقريتي بيت
[موسيقى]
عفا يوم من الايام اول يوم في
رمضان انا والله قاعد بخبز في الطابون في
حينه معاد السحور
بالضبط ما تخيلنا الا الخبط ما بندري من
وين بيجي اللي
هم اليهود
مطوق
البلد وبدهم
يحموها صاروا يطلعوا يجوا على باب الدار
يطقطق عليه من برا ويقولوا اللي في البيت
كله
يطلع طبعا احنا بقينا في بيت الجيران احنا
والجيران قاعدين سوا اطلعنا
الزلام قدامنا والنسوان انا بقى حياه
البكر على حضني عمره عش
اشهر حامله على حضني
هالحين طلعنا وحامله الولد على
دقيقه واحنا
ماشيين بقول ايش اللي
معك بقوله
بنت ققول لي ولد ولا بنت قلت له لا بنت
قال ايوه كان ولد بذبح هذا الكلام
الي هالحين في الحاله هذ سمعت الكلام هذا
خوفي وتكرس حي خايف يجي ياخذ الولد مني
يكشف عليه يلاقيه ولد يذبح الولد قدام
يكفيك شري ماشي ومش ماشي الى غايه ما
وصلنا الزلام والنسوان هذه كانت بين حياه
وبين
موت يعني كنت انا متوقع بس ربي
قصط في بلد هذه اللي هي هي اللي ربت لنا
الجرحه في قلوبنا اسمها دي ياسين اول اول
هجوم هجمو ذبحوه الاطفال والاختياريه
والنسوان ما عقبو فيهم حدا القريه هذه اول
هجوم هجموا عليها واول فضاع فضعوا
فيها فكنا احنا متوقعين يصير في بيت عفز
دير ياسين بس ربنا ستر واحنا من حيط لحيط
ومن دار لدار ومن بيت لبيت
ومن تبن لتبن ندفن حالنا احنا واولادنا
فيه حطيت ه
الولد
حطيت الخريطه هان اللي فيها ضاعه كلها
وقعدت الولد تقعيد عليها وانا حاط ايدي
هيك وبشا لاف على حالي ه
الا اربع
يهود ومعهم واحد عربي يعني اربع
اسرائيليين ومعهم وواحد عربي جايبينه
ماخذينه من من هو محبوس معهم ماخذينه مشان
يروحوا يشوفوا الدار ويجيبوا الرجال اللي
فيها
تلقيت انا وياهم عند اول
الصحر قال وين رايحه قلتله رايح على راح
على
دارنا قال وين دارك قلت هذ انت جيت
منها قام سعل اللي معهم ابن العرب حنيتها
هيك برت كرتك انا خايف يقولها مش
دارها قالله صحيح هذا
بيتها قالله اه
بيته قال طب يلا بروخ وبسد على حاله الباب
قلت له ماشي هم اخذوا الزلمه وظلوا نافدين
على البلد وانا جيت حطيت
حالي مع طول الحيط مع طول الباب اللي بدي
اخش فيه مع الحيط هيك وشرقت ولفيت
وندرت وطلعت بقت
اضره معرسه السلاف في العرنوس مش معرسه
وطالع العرنوس لافه وبده يبزر العرنوس
منها والعقول هطولي
الشوك وحامل الولد وحامل الشنط اللي خرفت
عنها وحالتي زي ولكن ما كذبش المثر انت
بقول جري الخوف ولا جري الطمع جري الخوف
اقوى
دخلت عصاب
كبيره في البلدان فشو انه اطلعوا تحر سبعه
ايام وتعود
ترجعوا والكذب هو اللي خرب ديارنا طلعنا
سبعه ايام هينا
قديش السبعه ايام
قديش وماحدش معترف
فينا حدت
فينا
[موسيقى]
ايش رايك في جيل اليوم يا حجه جيل اليوم
والله لا علي عتب ولا
علي اي جيل اليوم يعني من الم بتلاقي
لك زيع قرط ديك واسمعك في
جوزك امشي ما تتلفت وراك طب برض ما حكيتلي
ايش رايك في جيل اليوم جيل اليوم بقول
من بتطلعي اثنين اللي عليهم اللي عليهم
الارتكاب ليش طيب الجيل فيسبوك
هذا ولا من بنات البنت خرب قبل
اسلام اناجيل اليوم تقوليش
في مش
نافع مش
نافع هذا الجوال اللي حميت و ديار العالم
ليل ونهار وهي
ماسكته سياسيين كنا
سياسيين قالهن بدل هذا ما هي مسكته تمسك
لها ور تخيطه زي هذول وتحطهم في بيت
الوحده بدل ما بتلهي
حالها ايش الفرق بين جيل اليوم وجيل زمان
من الارض
للسماء اليوم
فنان جيل اليوم بقوللك جيل فيسبوك ما فيش
انت بتحكي جيل اليوم فنان اه فنان فنان بس
بدي يدم في في بعض من الناس كلك يا حال
اصلح من شي مش كله احكي عليه
[موسيقى]
كله والله لو بدي اقوللك مهما قك مش ح
تصدقيني اني لو اخسر اللي وراي واللي
قدامي ويسمحوا اني انا اعيش انا ك في ارضي
ووطني
لاعيش وما بدي ها ولا بدي الارض ولا بدي
البيارات
اللي لو في بياره وراي بدي اياها زما دشرت
دار بيت عف بدش طب مش هذا بيتك كمان بيت
لا بيت الاص
هذاك ما بيت الا بيت الله الاصل والفصل
اللي هو مسقط راسي
وقريتي
ووطني ووطني والله لو بدي اقول لك مهما
اقول لك مش ح
تصدقيني اني لو اخسر اللي وراي واللي
قدامي ويسمحوا اني انا اعيش هناك في ارضي
ووطني
الاعيش وما بدي هان ولا بدي الارض ولا بدي
البيارات اللي
[موسيقى]
ه
وبتمنى بتمنى من الله هيك بتمنى منك يا رب
اني ما اموت الا وانا راجع بيت عفا واموت
في تربه بيت عفا واندفن في صاح بيت
عف
[موسيقى]
k y